υπέρβαρος τούτα ανέχεις τουτα ταπάθει ισημαίνωι ότι εθισμένος άνθρωπος είσει αντίκτε ταεν και παρατέχονται το
κύπρα νομίζζω ότι ιπόε οι γυναίκα απου ναύρις να συνεξαρτημένοι για να τερκάζετεται κατασικά ένας
άνθρωπος έρχεται και σμί και παντρεύκεται ή κάμνι φίλους όσεξει να συγνεχίζω και πάρακατυψύφιζη βου
λευτές οι πρόεδρο τις δημοκρατίας τη είναι ότός τούτι τητούτος τούτόσο λαός ο κυπριακώ λαώραφιλε
είναι ψυχικά διαταραγμένος και θισμένος λαός στην πράξε πο σου λέω ο τώρα πορά πρά
τ τώρ να ρί φίλεε πόσους κουμαρτίες ξέρεις στην κύπρο πόσως που καπρίζου τιάρω πόσους
ξέρεις απαδούντις γυναίκες τους πόσος υπέρβαρούς που κάθονται πάστα τραπέζω σεφορτών του εφταγιά ουβλεπύρς καιτα
λιπά πόσους άρκι στους πόσου υπερόπτες και οπόσος που δουλεύκον δεγα υτώε την ημέρα για
τί κι τούτω δαδ πόσος ξέρει τούτι ανθρώποι ρεφιλέ εντούτι που απόφάσιζουν ιονα να ψηπήσουν
πράο πιασε στο εάρα από τις στημή ποόλα ωςεντων το πράμα ντα προδοο ένα υκάνου
αυκάνο ένα αγκαπνιστεί ν ρκολικών θ άσχε μπορεί τούτος πουν να υκή πρόεδρός όπω όπως
ήμουν και εγώ πω τους πά πωστ ανα σταεάδι σας ουσαάηταεκαιέχαλιγά λέβελτεκα ευτά ηλόγικίτου έχαε
νε θαύματα άνθρωπος αλλά έπινε το τσαρούε του το ποτόν του και γίνεται μάχι αρατόν
το άρατι θέλη του τη χώρα ικύπρος γα ναγια γιττη χώρα τούτουλλει που φοράζουν και
να πα στο προεδρικώ και τα λοιπά να αλλάξουν πράγματα ρεφετε θα αλλαξουν τίποτα σέρνουν
αυκάπα τους τοίχους τούτι χώρα για να αλλάξει πρέπει να αανεβούμε με επίπεδο δεείμαστε είπαστε
να πίπεδο δύοτρία τώρα και τα που σας λέω πολλά με λεδίμέα δηλαδή το επίπεδο
ένα ενα ψυχοτικός ο άνθρωπος ο ψυχωτικός είναι άνθρωπος οποίος για ανα σταματήσει τη φφωνή
που του μιλά μεσα στον κεφάλει του καταφεύγει στα σκληρ άρκοτικά το λεύελβο είνώ ψυχικά
διαταραγμένος άνθρωπος ο ψυχεάδι αταραμένος άνθρωπος είνα